good afternoon everyone my name is dr.
Miller and the SCP were going to be
looking at today is SCP 542 object class
Euclid special containment procedures
SCP 542 is to be kept in an 8 by 8 meter
room with small adjoining bathroom and
may submit requests for furnishings
barring anything that could be modified
into surgical tools notable requests by
a CP 540 to include one queen sized bed
no blankets or sheets bare mattress
approved two large work desks approved
one large wardrobe approved a selection
of heavy coats lab jackets and pants
approved several full-length mirrors
denied a selection of sewing supplies
along with bolts of cloth approved
initially but revoked after incident 542
b3 several large book cases filled with
anatomy and medical texts both old and
new approved a chess set approved blank
page notebooks and various writing
utensils approved regular supplies of
German language crossword puzzles
approved industrial grade deep sinks
denied steel nail file denied given
wooden sandpaper emery board and
replacement nail clippers denied and
access to his personal surgery kit
denied accepting cases of testing see
addendum
the room is to remain locked dead bolted
and barred with at least two Class D
guards on duty at any time as CP 542 is
to be fed two meals per day delivered by
Class D personnel and as per request
must be given a transfusion of fresh
blood one pint any type per week when
SCP 542 begins to suffer from organ
failure he may request a fresh organ to
be supplied and foundation medical
personnel will sedate him and perform
the surgery despite constant requests
SCP 542 may not be allowed to perform
invasive surgery upon himself except
during observed testing old and
discarded organs or tissue are to be
collected for testing in the event that
SCP 542 should escape confinement as CP
542 may be subdued by high doses of
tranquilizers or disabled via a net
should he come into possession of any
knives or shards of glass or mirror that
could be used to cut non-lethal fire is
permitted description SCP 542 claims
that it has been at one time a typical
human of Caucasian descent identifying
as German and nationality the story is
supported by the fact that German
appears to be his first language
speaking all other languages with a
German accent SCP 542 requests to be
called her Turk or surgeon by staff and
is fluent in German English and French
and can speak a small bit of Polish and
italian standard IQ tests have revealed
542 s IQ to range around 150 placing him
as high intelligence it is unknown how
old 542 is testing of various tissue
samples has revealed nothing he claims
to have been dreadfully normal before
World War one started and claims to have
worked for the party even if he found
their goals boringly simple
he has been described as Frankenstein's
monster in appearance SCP 542 may hide
his odd features under heavy clothing
but prefers to wear only a nice pair of
slacks revealing his hunched form
distended gut warped ribcage and bizarre
arm structure his skin is made from
patches of various hues and shades some
of these healed together with scars
while others are still stitched together
non symmetrical bone and muscle
structure reveals that he has replaced
the majority of his body over time and
admits to having worked with helpers
before to replace such things as
portions of his own spinal cord although
his appearance can change with surgery
his arms are always too long for his
body and his hands have been modified
greatly to have additional joints in the
fingers the skin is pulled rather
tightly over 542 s face giving him a
somewhat skeletal appearance along with
the tendency for his bones to bulge
through his skin his teeth it should be
noted are collected from different
individuals some of them not even human
by all appearances it is not uncommon
for him to cough or vomit blood and as
such requires infusions of fresh blood
approximately once per week he currently
boasts two hearts and multiples of
several other organs and organ systems
how 5:42 keeps track of his own
structure while performing surgery is
unknown but he likens it to having a
very good memory DNA testing on all
tissues is inconclusive and reveals
fragmented DNA it is unknown how he is
able to accept different blood types and
multiple organs without suffering from
organ rejection or allergic reactions
nor how he is able to function while
performing invasive surgery on himself
even while inserting extra brain matter
into his skull SCP 542 is to be kept
alive for observation and testing on the
process that keeps him alive
SCP 5:42 behaves in a surprisingly
Pleasant manner most of the time
enjoying lengthy conversations about
science and biology politics and long
games of chess however when an organ
begins to fail or part of his body
becomes necrotic he undergoes a drastic
personality change stalking and
observing people from a distance
additional information on his habits and
attacks may be found in the addendum SCP
542 appears to have a previously unknown
ability to be completely aware of his
body's functions and workings constantly
even able to identify points of rotting
or decay he should not be able to sense
my any known means this ability however
has been shown to extend beyond his own
body he can passively sense the health
and medical status of other humans
within several metres of him the range
extending to approximately 5 meters when
he focuses he admits that he uses this
process which she doesn't understand
himself to pick his next victims
addendum SCP 542 has been proven to be
the assailant in a string of 45 murders
over the course of three years that
occurred across Germany England and
America and is suspected of an
additional unconfirmed 15 murders in
that time span he was first observed
four years ago by agent in Germany after
four people had been attacked and had
muscle sinew and bones removed from
their limbs three of the victims died
from blood loss in shock the fourth
happened to be staying in the hotel room
next to agent who intervened this
account may be found in incident report
542 a AO 6s CP 542 has a strong
connection to a collection of scalpels
blades syringes and various other
surgical equipment from time periods
ranging from modern day to archaic if
very well kept relics from years as
early as the 1910s
he carries these in a velvet lined black
leather suit kicks and modifies many of
his jackets to have holders to hide and
carry his equipment in he is not allowed
access to this collection except during
testing and observation of self surgery
SCP 542 has also caused several deaths
of d-class personnel even when not in
testing due to negligence or assumption
that certain items may be safe when used
by him personnel are reminded that even
if his personality is pleasant the
majority of the time he will still
dissect personnel for amusement and
curiosity's sake if given the chance
these incidents may be reviewed in
incident reports 542 B Oh 1 through 5 42
B 11 seemingly safe items such as sewing
supplies have led to him making more
than a rather well tailored jacket for
himself but also resulted in him
restraining a Class D personnel by
sewing him into the mattress of the bed
before removing his kidneys and a
portion of the liver as CP 542 has shown
to be very willing to comply with
certain experiments and appears to enjoy
performing self surgery with someone
observing explaining what he's doing and
displaying his knowledge of the workings
of the body as if he were a teacher
describing a surgical textbook
unfortunately this usually requires
being at a risk of attack from him
it has been requested that SCP 5:42 be
kept alive so the process that allows
him to recover from intense surgery
without organ rejection be studied and
potentially copied for medical use SCP
5:42 may also show potential for being
used to assist in surgical and studying
endeavors due to his increased
intelligence and compulsion for
dissection any books and notes written
by him may be accessed and studied by
those with class two security clearance
or higher and this is update 2,000 SCP
542 has somehow acquired knowledge of
both SCP 291 and SCP 1025 and appears to
be very interested in their use all
requests to study both anomalies are to
be denied until further notice incident
report 542 a oh six agent while staying
at the hotel in germany heard the sounds
of a scuffle and screaming from across
the hallway at 3 a.m. local time at
which point he felt he had to intervene
unknown then he would come face to face
with a possible SCP after forcing the
door to his room he observed SCP 542
removing the muscles and bone of miss
his right leg after the agent fired
several shots
5:42 fled through the window and agent
contacted local authorities and an
ambulance
an American tourist who had only been in
town for a few days described what had
happened to her while recovering in the
hospital afterward she willingly took
the amnestic issue to her preferring to
believe that she had instead been in an
unfortunate traffic incident and her
right leg had been amputated her report
is as follows I had been to Germany
before so I knew my way around and I was
used to taking the bus but I guess I
first saw him there I think just this
guy all hidden under heavy jackets and
this hat and glasses and of course I was
suspicious because it was summer you
know just weltering hot and I realized
he was looking at me but I ignored it he
didn't get off the bus at my stop
anyways and there were always others on
the bus even late at night I guess I saw
him for three days and I stopped
thinking about it he must have followed
me off the bus then that day that night
I went up to my hotel room and I don't I
don't remember the window was open and
it was all dark the light wouldn't turn
on I figured somebody had decided to
steal my stuff so I went in to see if
anything was missing and shows signs of
intense discomfort and asks for a minute
to compose herself this is allowed and
she resumes after several minutes he was
hiding under the bed and he had these
freakishly long arms and the fingers too
many joints and he took my ankles right
out from under me he was just too fast
and he tied my arms and legs to the bed
and at first I thought you know that he
was going to
you know kept saying things like don't
worry in you're going to help me and I
need your help and things like that
it was scary as [ __ ] and he said that's
so long as I kept quiet he might call an
ambulance afterward and that was a
little scary
I guess it really was worse than that he
picked up his jacket it had been on the
coat hanger by the door and I hadn't
even noticed it started pulling out all
these knives and all these tools and I
just didn't know what to do so I decided
to take my chances and started screaming
as loud as I could and he was allowed to
stop there and was delivered they
amnestic and alibi that night incident
report 542 a 15-4 details on the
eventual tracking and capture of SCP 542
please refer to a request for
declassification is under review mm note
as of SCP 5 42 has been moved to bio
research area 12 in order to assist in
the Olympia project dr. writes is said
and I quote I want to back intact
further note SCP 542 has somehow
acquired information of SCP 291 827 and
545 investigation into the extent of 542
s knowledge of these SCPs and how he
acquired this knowledge is currently
under investigation offending personnel
will be disciplined appropriately
following a board review oh five
I don't know about all of you but I
think using scps as surgeons is a really
bad idea
does no one remember scp-049 breaching
containment these things you know what
I'm just gonna leave here okay thank you
all for listening if indeed you still
are
and you were all dismissed goodbye
I would like to give a special thank you
to Bob the reclusive extrovert GM's
Sabha arbiters soul
Darius Tom Karim L ash mooing Justin day
Oh philia gray Thomas Morin Curie kuma
Aaron Peck and jayvo Jack dr. crystal
spice my archive curator Nick Joseph
Lewis ooh agent vamp King modding and
dr. Proctor thank you all so much for
your support
it's greatly appreciated if you would
like a special thank you at the end of
each of my videos on some other cool
stuff as well visit patreon.com forward
slash the volga thank you
[Music]
you